congrats man on all your success bro
thank you so what's your name away from
ezekiel i'm from london from london yeah
and when did you decide you wanted to
get into property i'll say from october
2019 i saw a video with you and patricia
bright oh wow yeah so we can thank
auntie aunty pat yeah basically yeah wow
so you saw me working with um patricia
bright doing a collab with her and what
was it about that interview that made
you like yes in the interview that
you've done he started talking about
renter and you start talking about deals
yeah and obviously i've never heard of
those things before you know so from
that moment i realized there must be
other ways to get into property yeah i
think from that moment i began to like
binge watch all your videos about rent
to rent about deal sourcing i began to
read your books i read one of your books
that you've done and yeah i just told
myself that i think this is something i
want to do and at this point just after
that we went into like full on lockdown
around about march 2020 and that was
when we put all of our training programs
online which i know you went through
yeah yeah yeah so that's exactly what
i've done i saw that you were releasing
all your videos and you put it online
and you done it for one pound and i took
full advantage of that
so yeah i'll write your videos great man
and when did you get your first rental
rant so my first rent to rent was in
april 2021 and that came after eight
months of trying to source a deal so i
had no success and literally in april i
was ready to pack in so after eight
months of constantly calling landlords
20 landlords a day i was ready to
literally just pack up property in and
then spoke to one of my friends danny
and he said try rent to rent and then
within two weeks of me trying that i got
my first deal nice so if anyone doesn't
know what what is rent to rent so rent
to rent is essentially you taking a
property from a landlord or an agent you
agree on a management contract for a
rent for about three to five years you
guarantee the rent deal all maintenance
and yeah give a hands-off experience to
landlords and agents so what do you
think from a landlord's perspective like
right now what are the advantages if i'm
a landlord and i've got a property and
you want to take it off me on a rental
rent what's the advantage to me what
would i not just write down myself
personally i feel like as someone who's
busy most landlords can be busy
especially portfolio landlords and when
they know that they're getting a
hands-off experience all maintenance
everything is dealt with you know i feel
like it's a win-win you know they don't
have to have the stress of dealing with
tenants or dealing with all the ongoing
costs you know they just know that every
single month they're gonna get their
rent on time yeah yeah yeah okay so for
them it's just ease lack of hassle and
then what are you getting out of it if
you're just renting a property off of me
how are you making money so i get the
profit after all the bills are paid you
know after the rent is paid i get a
profit from the property so you're
renting it out as like a hmo or
something yes i'll have some hmos and
have some service accommodation okay
cool man so right now how much are you
making from your rent to rents alone so
each of them bring in about 800 i'll
save my my service accommodation both of
them probably bring in about a thousand
pounds a month and 70 occupancy okay so
how many of you got in total now so i've
got five five and they're making about
800 each yeah so probably around 4k a
month profit 4k profit and on top of
that you're also deal sourcing yeah
ideal source as well um yeah try to aim
for about three a month yeah sourcing
yeah so you're kind of on between sort
of like seven and nine thousand pounds
yeah yeah so you're making a few grand
from your deal sourcing yeah and then
about four or five grand from your
rental rental yeah exactly yeah so why
are you still working so for me
personally i feel like when you have a
full-time job what is your job i work in
a private school a learning mentor yeah
so working with kids with learning
difficulties and behavior problems um so
yeah for me working in a full-time job
you have that security knowing that
you're going to get x amount at the end
of a month and because of business
there's so many ongoing costs so for me
i know that
if i spend x amount i have security for
my job and although i don't need to work
in my job you know i feel like one is
quite quite rewarding you know with the
kids helping out the kids but also too
it allows me to scale my business much
quicker because i'm looking to take on a
new deal every month but is you is your
job making as much money as your
business no my job is making far less i
think
from deal free i didn't need to work at
my job yeah i still chose to work on you
enjoy your job yeah i enjoy it but i
definitely feel like it's probably
coming towards the end yeah yeah so
right now in 2022 do you think this
business model still works 100 100
percent and yeah service accommodation i
only go into it recently and honestly i
love it yeah i lost it it's
accommodation so so talk to me about
your first deal give me the figures how
did you find it where did you find it
yeah cool so this first still was from
an agent it was on the market for about
four months yeah and
i phoned him he told me that it was a
four bed it was previous uses a hmo um
for stroke five um it was listed for
eighteen hundred in northwest london um
i managed to get down to seventeen
hundred um
and yeah that that property is probably
bringing me about nine hundred i'd say
and you rent that out room by room yeah
how do you get the tenants so the
tenants i use like spare room if i want
everyone's from the spare room to be
honest yeah so yeah that was pretty
straightforward are you worried that the
rental rents will dry up and you won't
be able to find tenants and the tenants
will move out i don't think i will you
must be a little bit worried because you
said about the security of your job yeah
no to be honest the only reason security
of the job is like i'm thinking of the
maintenance costs like my recent hmo and
it's a seven bid like every single month
like something whether it's the radio
whether it's the series right right so
when i think of those okay so it's not
about the tenants moving no it's not
about the tenants because i feel like
everyone's always looking for rooms
what's the agreement you have with the
landlord does the landlord have to pay
for some of the maintenance yes the
landlord doesn't have to pay for
anything under 150 i think i'll cover
the occasion
okay so that's not going to bankrupt
your man if like yeah no wouldn't it but
but still though there are costs exactly
how much money did you have when you
started the business
so i had quite a bit from savings so
from age 21 from 19 i had like two
pounds in my account so from 19 to age
23 i'll just save and say
and so i had a reserve of money i had
about like 17k wow yeah have you put all
edge rental ramps basically yeah okay so
you pay all your money to an extent
actually yeah i'll take a large majority
of it into rental rent so that i can
scale pretty quickly but then you made
that back exactly i made it back here so
what how do you work out how much to put
into a rental rent because if someone
comes along says to me i got a rent to
rent but i need to put down 10 grand
is that not a bit risky yeah definitely
has to be risky i feel like you need to
look at how much you have coming in i
feel like you need to properly evaluate
the deal you know you can't just take
any deal for the sake of taking a deal
yeah yeah the numbers have to make sense
i try to make my money back within about
seven months okay so yeah that's kind of
that's our role we've said six months
yeah if you can't make your money back
in six months then then don't do it
exactly if you can make your money back
in six months if you put down three
grand and you're making 500 a month yeah
that's gonna take you six months to make
it back and then everything after that's
profit exactly so now you're at a point
where you're making like four grand a
month conservatively on your rental
rents yeah but that's now coming in
you've paid yourself back and your
profit exactly so you've basically
replaced your income yeah yeah so
um talk to me about the
time management of running this rental
rent business and having a job and doing
deal sorting on top how do you find the
time
to fit i feel like it's all about making
priorities you know if i'm honest
my business kind of comes first
you know obviously my school don't want
to hear that but in terms of me waking
up early i have to wake up early to try
and work on the business any lunch time
any breaks that i have i needed to work
on a business after work working on a
business so for me
every single time i have every minute i
have i try and use it to grow my
business okay how do you school feel
about you having how does your job feel
about you having a business on the side
to fit they're actually quite supportive
because i feel like it gives the kids
something to look look up to yeah i feel
like in this day and age unfortunately a
lot of kids don't have the best role
models yeah so i feel like when they
have somebody in the school who's quite
active and has things outside school
going pretty well i feel like it's up to
them to aspire to what any property
solutions yeah your name's ezekiel so
so it's pronounced that easy property
solution as in i want to create an easy
solution right landlord's problem yeah
yeah i like that my name's ezekiel i
like that because that's that's business
business is about solving problems
exactly and you know what in business
you have to be able to sell i don't know
if you've whether you've found that like
dealing with landlords tenants you have
to you can't just get a property and
just put it on spare room and it rents
out 100 you have to sell the room you
can't just say to a landlord drop a
message on on on gumtree or or open rent
on spare room and do all the
negotiations over sparing no you've got
to pick up the phone you've got to get
in front of them you have to sell
exactly yeah right talk to me about
sales
sales is everything and one thing i've
realized is that before sales you have
to focus on the relationship you know i
feel like property is not just about
houses it's about people you know when
people have a problem you know that's
when you can come in and solve their
problem yeah you know so i feel like one
way to build a report before focusing on
sales is focusing on them you know what
problem are you having with your house
like why do you want to get rid of it
okay you want to guarantee the rent i
can help you with that yeah so that's
some people get upset with me for
selling my one pound course
and i'm like if you're upset of me for
selling your one one-pound course then
you're not going to be able to sell to
landlords and sell to tenants if you're
like oh man don't sell to me exactly i'm
not trying to sell you a one-pound
course to get rich you paid me one pound
exactly yeah
but for me that's just because i want a
tiny commitment from you exactly yeah so
there's a little bit of a sting um
and i sold to you and now you've got the
training yeah you're now selling to
landlords yeah probably the best pack
you ever spent definitely was
so okay what are the problems then with
rent two months talk to me about some of
the challenges you've had oh tenants my
first deal i was so desperate for
tenants picked the wrong tenants i mixed
one social house tenant with four
professionals out and when everyone was
working she was at the home stealing
their food
yeah she had another guy around around
the house smoking in a in a room yeah he
was complaining i've once had one turn
at one guy um trying to get him out of
the property he should be leaving end of
the month he's behind on his rent um
three months three years running on his
rent um the reason why i got like that
is because he lost his job i kind of
felt sorry for him um that's one thing i
realized as well you can't be too too
nice no it's not too too nice people
take advantage right and they'll come up
with stories man exactly exactly and
that's exactly what happened with this
guy um he said he lost his job whether
that's true or not i don't know but yeah
gotta have compassion but also the bible
talks about be as innocent as a dove but
as wise as a serpent yeah and it's like
being kind and innocent and pure and
compassionate but also not being a mug
exactly yeah so
how stressful was that how stressful did
you find that i was like a young
entrepreneur honestly like because
sometimes i wake up and i'm just like
annoyed yeah i'm just looking at my
phone like because he's ignoring my
calls on purpose so for me that was
frustrating with the girl she managed to
get out pretty quickly because she was
provided by the council so she didn't
want any of her benefits to be revered
did you have to confront her yeah yeah
that and that's the only way because she
was she was ignoring my email she was
like so did you go around to the house
yeah i went to the house how old are you
i'm 24 gonna be 25 in june 24. so 24
year old having to like deal with
problems like this yeah yeah exactly
some people aren't cut out for that i
know honestly people can't do that they
can never for sure for sure because
that's challenging man exactly even my
latest one um one of my latest one the
one i got in january using seven bid all
the tenants there are all older than me
like
yeah and my first my first experi
encounter with them was telling them
that their rent was gonna go up because
obviously he wasn't making as much
profit and you know one of the guys who
was like 45 you know he was squaring up
to me
because i told him that his rent was
going to go up by 35 pounds you know i
gave him a month's notice and his
contract was coming to an end anyway
yeah he didn't like it so yeah he wanted
to fight me damn yeah rough bro hello
did you find him no no
no he's a good tenant you know what
though i've taught a lot of people in
property and
someone that some of the um
some of these challenges they're not
used to exactly and it's like what do i
do with this i got this guy squaring up
to me do i fight him yeah and it's like
no you have to be professional follow
follow the book follow the business
exactly so okay so the biggest problems
and biggest challenges have been with
tenants yeah for sure have you grown
through that 100 and that's the thing i
feel like a lot of people
don't want adversity but i feel like
it's the adversity that strengthens you
right and i feel like all those
experience allow me to look back on it
and learn from it and i feel like a loss
isn't a loss when you learn from it i
feel like it's a lesson
and i feel like all lessons are when i
was when i was 17 18 years old i had
some like hmos yeah and had the same
thing like sometimes the tenants didn't
want to pay and i remember being like oh
maybe i needed to get my mom to call
them or something and then i thought you
know what i need to stop being a person
exactly this is my property they're my
tenants this is my money i need to just
deal with this and when i did obviously
it was hard but you think actually this
is part of the business by the time i
was 19 i'd see other 19 year olds
and
met mentally and experienced and like
they're on a different planet
you know they're worried they're worried
to call their friends because they don't
they don't feel comfortable on the phone
they like to text and i'm having to go
and face people and kick them out
you know so you grow you do grow through
it and i think your problems today
you'll look back on in five years time
and realize they weren't problems they
were tiny the problems i have are way
bigger than the problems you have
right
they're way bigger but it's like
if i'm speaking to
richard branson he'll probably look at
my problems and think they're tiny yeah
and you just got as an entrepreneur
on the very definition of an
entrepreneur as a problem solver yeah
he's solving problems for landlords and
tenants and giving people solutions so
what's been what would you say has been
the moment like the best moment where
you were like oh my goodness this is
actually working like did you when you
when you were going through the training
videos during lockdown when i put that
offer out one pound that's crazy right
yeah very crazy everyone else was in
hibernation all the other property
trainers were in hibernation
meanwhile i'm like winners on a
wednesday every week still doing my
training putting it all online but like
at what point did you realize that this
is actually possible and did you see the
money coming in did you realize yes i
feel like when i got to deal four
that's not that long it took that long
because my first three deals i was like
yeah you know it's going pretty well but
i feel like deal four actually realized
like wow that this is actually going
pretty well in the space of 12 months
i've
got taken on five properties but it was
deal four that actually made me realize
that wow this is going really well yeah
yeah yeah
and
what would you say to someone wanting to
do what you've done
what advice would you give them to take
like the steps and stuff to get started
from the early days do you feel a lot of
people ask me that question and my
answer is always the same i feel like
you have to get educated you have to
know what you want what you're getting
yourself into yeah you know you can't
just go to a landlord and say you're
going to guarantee them rent you know
you're only going to get a rejection so
for me i feel like before anything you
need to invest in yourself and get
educated and even if that's a pound like
i'm still running pound courses now the
only difference is i'm doing them in
person um so okay what would you say is
your strongest reason because you've had
to hustle man you've had to go out there
you got rejected again and again what
was your reason what was the burn where
did that burn come from for me i want to
change my family's life and to feel not
just my family but those around me you
know for me cherry's a massive thing i
want to be in a position to be able to
give back to build orphanages schools
hospitals you know but you can't help
others if you first can't help yourself
right and i realized that from an early
age so for me that's one thing that
drives me just being that person who can
be able to help others and give back
yeah man that's good i believe that it's
similar for me you know when i got
started what's next then for ezekiel
what's next for easy property solutions
for me i want to take on a property
every month so by the end of the year i
want to be like earning ten thousand
pounds a month profit yeah um and next
year we're not too far bro yeah yeah and
next year potentially going into like
brrs up north um so yeah that's the plan
dude bigger respect man thank you thank
you for coming out final words of wisdom
for the viewers
just believe in yourself just believe
yourself and trust the process i feel
like life is not easy it's full of
challenges ups and downs but the
challenges are only going to help you
grow and get to where you want to be at
the right time i'd like to say about
trust the process because ultimately
this business is a process if you do abc
you're going to get you just you know
two plus two is four it's the same with
this business if you do this this this
in this way you're gonna get the results
sometimes people doubt themselves
because maybe they're um you know their
gender or where they're from or they
think can i do this my family like even
me i was like i'm not hungry university
in my family but it's like you know what
yeah this is possible if samuel can do
it ezekiel can do it if ezekiel can do
it then the next person can do it so
thanks for coming down to my house
appreciate the story it's inspirational
and uh i look forward to keep in touch
thank you
[Music]